In the MCU, everyone's favorite foul-mouthed,
trigger-happy rodent has always been known as
"Rocket." But where did he get his name? And what
species is he really? Warning! Spoilers ahead!
As the last movie in James Gunn's trilogy of
sci-fi epics, "Guardians of the Galaxy Vol.
3" sends off its team of misfits in high
fashion. Rather than saving the universe,
this time around the gang is on a mission
to save Rocket's life. But to do so,
they'll have to scour their friend's
past and find a way to bypass a kill
switch activated inside of him. As the story
unfolds, the audience is treated to flashbacks
of Rocket's origins. In them, we learn how he
was experimented on by the High Evolutionary
to become the hyper-intelligent,
jaded rodent we all know and love.
Audiences get to see Rocket go from a baby raccoon
to a creature learning the basics of science,
all the way to innovating on the High
Evolutionary's processes. And naturally,
there's a point where the audience learns where
Rocket got his namesake. As the High Evolutionary
teaches Rocket, the little mammal sees a ship take
off and correctly identifies it as a "rocket."
Later, when Rocket and his cohorts are in
their cages, they discuss naming themselves.
This is a small act of rebellion against the
High Evolutionary and the designations he's
given them. Rocket's friends name themselves
Lylla, Teefs, and Floor. When it's Rocket's
turn he recalls how he has always dreamt
of going into the sky and remembers the
ship escaping the power of gravity. In that
fateful moment, he gives himself his true name.
Given his tragic upbringing, it's
no surprise that Rocket is deeply
insecure about his body and his place
in the world. He has a long history of
getting offended when people refer to him as
an animal. He's been called everything from
a rabbit to a badger. Peter Quill calls him a
raccoon, an animal Rocket has never heard of.
"What's a raccoon?"
"What's a raccoon? It's what you are, stupid."
"Ain't no thing like me, 'cept me."
Each time he's compared to an animal, Rocket
explodes in anger. He's always viewed himself
as one-of-a-kind, so being compared to a rodent or
a critter is perhaps the greatest insult to him.
However, Rocket's sense of self is challenged
when he finds a lab on the High Evolutionary's
ship housing other animals, including a cage
of baby raccoons. As Rocket opens the cage,
and the babies quickly flock to
him he sees a label. And it's at
that moment that Rocket learns what
he's been all along — a raccoon.
In the comics, "Rocket" has always been
"Rocket Raccoon," but explaining his species
in the movies has been on the back burner
in the MCU where he's only been referred to
as "Rocket." That changes during his final
confrontation with the High Evolutionary,
as Rocket lets him know once and for all that he's
not just an experiment. He's "Rocket Raccoon."
It's a celebratory moment where Rocket
fully embraces who he is. He's spent a
lifetime running away from his past and
the painful memories that lurk there.
But with one defiant statement, he makes it
clear that the High Evolutionary no longer
controls him. Rocket's calling the shots
from now on, and he has his family to back
him up. With their help, Rocket takes
on the High Evolutionary one last time.
Rocket is indeed a raccoon, and it's nothing for
him to be ashamed of. After all the trauma and
abuse he endured, he's finally come to accept
where he's from. This newfound sense of place
and identity allows him to move on as the
new captain of the Guardians of the Galaxy.